I can
we got a spark
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking in the sky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning trust it is a rainy and
messy Tuesday in New York rain hail
sleet snow you know there's a storm
coming this way but thank God there are
two you know rays of sunshine sitting in
front of you just brightening up this
foggy gloomy ominous Tuesday morning
it's sure we're bringing the heat today
that we are bringing in the he you would
never know that we're in the middle of a
winter storm considering I'm baring my
leg right incredibly brave I can leave
an uneven wearing so much as a panty
hose not even a panty hose because I
need to stock up on new panty hose by
the way the most underrated underrated
feminine item in the world is a nude
panty hose there is a new brand that
I've been seeing a lot of toasters post
about in the beginning a lot of targeted
ads for it that is claiming to be like
an unwritten like sheer I've seen it I
would be interested for you to try them
let me know I would love to try it I
wouldn't be surprised if skin starts
making a nude panty hose because it's
incredible and like you feel like an ice
skater yeah um no but I came up with
this idea for this outfit in my head
last night like wow I was falling asleep
like that I want to wear this sweatshirt
with a skirt and so then I had to see it
through you know I knew that I wanted to
wear this crust Amaris wet shirt because
it is my favorite end from the merch
collection but I didn't know that it had
like oil french fry stains like all over
it do you see them here no I know hair
is covering it and then also I keep
noticing new stains on the wrists like
maybe it's time I wash it unclear but
it's like a treasure map of all your
memories you know by the way all the
snacks you've had all the snacks that
I've had in all the places that I'm in
because I bring this on tour with me
it's the most comfortable thing to fly
in and you know I eat like an animal in
an airport so there has like some
potatoes from like the Chicago Airport
like I'm just I'm all over the place but
I don't really care because they hold a
lot of value and a lot of memories for
me totally I love all of our merchants
like our children and don't ask me to
pick some of my favorites but I will say
that that's what you're that you're
wearing is undoubtedly the most
comfortable of anything that we've made
top 5 of my favorite designs number one
of my favorite quality of comfort and
that is the cross to bear for watching
as a podcast it says that's just my
cross to bear and then by the stain on
the breast it says the morning test that
asked
toaster it is world-renowned for its
come penis excel and it is available at
chatting to us Tommy restocked it that's
why as is this crap sweatshirt that I'm
wearing I'm wearing assembly hall that's
my favorite item oh I love it with the
pants
um I'm wearing a size small right now
but I actually if I could do it all over
again I might actually get an extra
small because I want it even more
cropped so don't worry if you think it's
too cropped for you ever like on camera
light no I've never ordered an extra
small anything in my life
speaking of camera light um a very
famous Geoffrey start phrase he did a
podcast yesterday that was a tough
segment I couldn't think of the word
phrase he did a podcast yesterday he was
on Trisha Paytas his podcast which I
believe comes out today that I'm
definitely going to be listening to and
that's not why I'm bringing it up I'm
bringing it up because I feel as though
we are one step closer to possibly
getting Geoffrey on toast yeah like Jeff
found the toast but um Jeff on he's just
not a Jeff you know I mean no he was a
Jeff when he made that video with the
Dolan twins he was Jeff totally um but
also I didn't know the Trisha Paytas had
a podcast and her studio is so [ __ ]
cute so here is hosting us to shame
she's putting us to shame yeah a little
Instagram sure we've got to get Jeff on
the toast dad to 2020 goal for sure
write it down write it down you're right
you're right what we wrote down um
you'll find out when you pull up here
know I had so many when you pull up here
a little list you'll see sibling rivalry
oh god that seems like so far Jeffery on
the toast okay I need to write down I
need to separate this is 2020 okay I
guess sibling are below it sounds like
really like a a pipe dream honest that's
Kate Hudson's podcast where she has
siblings on so like obviously high right
at at some point they will get desperate
enough to have us on now totally like
and honestly been seeing some of the
guests that they haven't I feel like
they're definitely getting desperate
there aren't that many siblings
I mean it's ship it okay maybe what
they're having famous people on and
they're totally irrelevant like non
famous siblings right oh not famous
sibling Oh
so that really wide right you can have
you know Demi Moore and her sister that
nobody's ever heard I was like all of
her kids right oh that would actually be
good that would be cute okay very
interesting we're gonna be working
towards our goals um I can't believe
2020 it's just right around the bend I
cannot believe it's right around the
bend and you know I am when the year
comes to an end you really take a look
at like your life and you know the world
that you're living in
and I went to dinner last night with my
friends from high school and they're
really like they have to pull their
pulse their finger on the pulse of like
what's going on in the world they're
very like in tune and especially in New
York and there's like so much crap going
on in New York they like I didn't even
know about did you hear about that
Barnard student who was stabbed in the
park
30 times yes I did and she died and when
he the man tried to mug her and she was
like absolutely not and she fought back
and he stabbed her 30 times and she's
still in times you called episode she
did you try and get help and then she
died yeah horrible horrible like a nice
girl from West Virginia yeah I saw it on
New York one it's such a sad story the
community up in ha by Columbia and the
students are really coming together and
like people want answers in the city
it's not a safe city no it's not a safe
city even though like I hate to make a
joke but really all goes back to just
like the way the city's being run no
completely and then also I saw a video
that they were showing me these videos
of this woman literally on a subway she
got punched in the face because this
woman was like attacking a man with
wearing a yarmulke and she was like stop
that [ __ ] and she got punch to the Beast
yeah I saw her I saw her scar on her
face I can't
and then in Beverly Hills synagogue was
totally vandalized they like ruined all
the Seifert or us like like destroyed
them like I can't you guys it's a
nationwide problem it's not just New
York but it just feel like when you're
in New York and your Jewish person
living in New York like you hear about
all these terrible things happening but
you know it can never happen in New York
because New York is like the Israel of
America like all the Jews in the world
live in New York like some people live
in America they never beverage person in
their life but if you live in New York
you know a million Jewish people like
just things like that don't happen in
New York so then with like the journey
they haven't the most in New York I get
in Brooklyn like in Borough Heights like
where there's the most Jews oh I'm
always hearing about like crazy things
happening to Jews in like Europe no I'm
like it feels so distant but like you're
like safe in New York because New York
is like Jew labs no I'm always seeing
surveillance footage of like some kids
like beating up oh that's true like old
Jewish man be on the street yeah okay
that's a good point too it just feels
like it's happening a lot recently I
feel like it wouldn't happen in LA like
that like you know actually I'm actually
always hearing about like we're like no
kidnapping no but like it happens
everywhere no I'm saying that's what
that's like I'm yeah I add this point in
New York I'm so desensitized to like all
of the violence is really well it needs
to stop I'm not down no it's it's it's a
scary time for sure and honestly I think
I'm gonna start taking the subway just
to patrol anti-semitism and like hate
crime
because I'm just feeling brave like I
always think like if I was on the subway
like what would I have done you know I
said I'd like to think that I would be a
hero and like stand up for myself or
someone else so I'm just gonna start
patrolling the subway and I bring a
baton with me and just like see any
indiscretion like I'm getting involved
bringing that baton yeah it's like scab
students student council against bullies
only the subway needs a scab but they
real I mean they do you would think oh
my god this somebody needs a scab and
then all the students would just pile
around the one Jewish kid and like you
know wait till the stop and let them get
off oh my god that's hilarious you
shouldn't you should do that we need the
kid from good boys
we the proud scab member anyways what a
what a lovely Tuesday here it here in
the big city how was your day yesterday
my day yesterday was good it was very
productive we did a patron episode that
will be released on Friday when we are
no longer here oh I worked out to the
point of nearly fainting and who live
method it was like the worst it's ever
been in terms of I can't believe I
haven't passed out there sooner like
feeling pain and queasy who've ever
thrown up there no but that was the
closest I've ever come I was literally
like not well [ __ ] and then I was home
I worked on today's episode of the
snatchler Murray Mian premium stuff
they're breaking down Peter's girls
they're actually being really funny and
not too mean about it which was I was
proud of my little snitch did you see
they made a revolutionary update in The
Bachelor girl photograph process and let
them stand on a white background
yeah oh my god all the photos like some
girls were like movie stars and other
girls were like bachelor in the 90s
right and it's really unfair it's really
unfair Beckett Italy like was tweeting
about how they're you like the making
the change from blue to white background
it's like so unfair like it is so much
better
ya know the girls were looking like the
snatchler yes not sure is the only one
who can break it down so head properly
snatchler to listen it's good stuff yeah
I had such a like I was really feeling
on like emotional spiritual high after
talking to Andy Grammer yesterday I feel
like he's like a priest yeah and like
you could just like talk to him and like
feel good you know well a good priest
like but honestly it doesn't surprise me
that he was so in tune like mentally
perfectly spiritually because his music
is that so he just jumps off the page
and so this morning I was listening to
my Spotify most-played 2019 list and
getting goodbye Lauren Alaina was on
there
and actually Damned Andy Grammer because
I feel like that song was exactly what
we were talking about yesterday do you
know what I mean like yeah well you
always think like your life is gonna be
great when you get to a certain point
and then you get there it's like no it's
the next thing yep so I DM him I wonder
if answered I was like you should listen
to the song where Lord Elena I felt like
Sookie I don't know if it's weird to
like recommend a song to like a singer
um to find out also speaking of crime in
New York I just got an Amber Alert oh
let's check your local media looks like
they won't even give you the deets wait
that's so like um oh yeah other people
in the group got the Amber Alert
Bronx New York check your local media
that is the weirdest thing ever
yeah like we are your local media right
now and we don't know I'm gonna I'm not
a Google search local media New York
wine oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we need Roma
Tory here
totally whatever happened to justice for
Roma Tory did she get her justice I'm
not sure I'm pretty sure she's still in
New York one no no I see everything else
though things must've they must have
gotten some bit of justice Amber Alerts
are like the scariest thing ever I know
it's like the worst thing ever people
are just like supposed to go on with
their day after getting that
notification like a child is missing
yeah
tragic tragic but I'm glad that we have
them that's like a very Intune thing
considering we all have cell phones and
we can all be useful be helpful yeah
that's so true I think that was like a
if there's a study of like with the
invention of like Amber Alert on your
phones are just like phones in general
like people being able to record stuff
like does that help crimes getting
solved or not cuz like it could help
because like there's always someone
around like knowing a picture of what
you look like if you put out a want and
you could see you know you can reach a
million people then it's like everyone's
so like on their phones are not even
looking around yeah it has to have
helped but maybe like technology has
also helped people commit crimes to know
their crimes and more help which reminds
me that I know you're obsessed with
American greed and I've been watching
channel 15 CNBC like every night before
bed because they play Shark Tank reruns
and they were implying they were playing
American greed and I was going about to
change a channel but then Alexis Neiers
popped up and I was like what the [ __ ]
is she doing on American greed I didn't
realize they did a whole episode on the
Bling Ring and it was actually
fascinating and they really didn't
ignore the pretty wild of it all like
they were talking about how reality and
reality television collided it was
actually a really well done good episode
and they got her there like right after
she got out of jail oh and they also
mentioned that she happened to be in
jail when Lindsay Lohan had to go to
jail for a short period of time and she
was in jail for robbing Lucy's house and
Lindsay goes to jail too so they were
jailed same time that's crazy
yeah
I'm so glad that you've been watching
American greed yeah bed was like not
into it so I just like kept having to
pause and explain to him and I showed
him the video of her Alexis Neiers
calling Nancy Joe I just tried to give
him like some cultural context like he
couldn't care less it's so important
live date like it you can't appreciate
it it's so hard like trying to make
people care about things that they don't
care about but that you do care about
cuz like it hurts your feelings when
they like aren't paying attention
no it cuts deep it cuts deep that's why
you should only hang out with you
because he cares
honestly if by that logic I shouldn't
literally only hang out with you because
we have the same exact interests except
for friends and hallmark movies true
we're so dissimilar in so many ways and
actually so funny that you and I
actually like the same opinion on
everything the same interest because
like Loki you like there are two
different types of girls and it's us
yeah you know yeah result interesante
okay well I think it's time because
we've got some good stories for you
today so without further ado we're gonna
hit you with the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
for sure oh do you do you smell that
smells amazing smells like someone's
signing on and smelling amazing that's
you don't say it definitely is oh my
gosh this episode is brought to you by
centered did you know that scent is the
most powerful sense you have a smell can
bring on a flood of memories influence
your mood and of course enhance your
natural style but while you're looking
for that signature scent that will make
you stand out and keep the memory of you
lingering on why waste so much time and
money with cheap knockoffs and
half-empty bottles of failed experiments
with sin burn you can have great taste
and mix up your fragrance routine
without ever breaking the bank
whether it's Tom Ford gucky or verse ace
Gucci of Versace Sandburg comm keeps you
smelling good month after month Sanford
is a luxury fragrance subscription
service for perfumes and colognes they
have more than 600 designer brands for
you to choose from you choose a perfume
you want to try each month they'll send
you a 30 day supply if you're not sure
what type of scent you're looking for
you can sort and find your new fragrance
by brand style occassion season and more
so I started using Sanford when they
signed on and smelled amazing for the
toast
like a year ago and I was trying
different stuff like Gucci Bulgari
and then I found one that I just liked
and now I just use it cuz I've always
wanted to be like that girl yeah where
it's like I leave and everyone knows I
was there because I farted because it's
maple they send and they know well we
actually are past the maple based scent
time period
now you're going more for a peppermint
pine they sent peppermint eggnog feel
warm Lodge you know love it hot cocoa
love that um plus save other products
from other categories like skincare
wellness and makeup they carry brands
from cope re glam glow glow recipe tart
and so many others and we have an
exclusive offer just for our listeners
so you can get 30% off your first month
today that's only 10 dollars for your
first fragrance go to scent bird comm
slash steen or offer exchange we used to
have at every one now it's scent bird
calm / teens to make sure you're
listening or just use the code Steen for
30% off your first month again that's
scent bird comm scen t-bird dot-com /
teen or use just the code steam ste n
for you to try your first perfume or
cologne for just $10 Simon's smell
amazing
Wow you know how people do affirmations
in the mirror every morning you is good
you ascribe right I think that like one
obviously should do good morning Matt
nobody needs to feel better and also do
a sign on smell amazing like you will be
you'll feel ready to ask for that raise
I used to think that doing affirmations
was like one of the lamest things you
could do and like people who needed
affirmations like just need help you
know but I do affirmations before my
show and it's like literally the only
thing that helps in like now I'm
thinking maybe I should do it every day
right you would just have such a pep in
your step they really like it gets you
in the space to like just kill it you
know I talk to myself I'm like you are
literally the smartest funniest coolest
girl in the world like you're gonna go
out there and like just make people
laugh like you're amazing you are
descendent of God like I'm really like I
get insane but it helps okay are you
ready for our first story this stories
are some hot actually just one low but
we're starting on a high okay wish come
true Mariah Carey's all I want for
Christmas is you hits number one on the
Hot 100
after 25 year weight completing the
journey 25 years in the making Mariah
Carey's 1994 Carol all I want for
Christmas is you crowns the Billboard
Hot 100 for the first time jingling
three one on the chart two sick dated
December 21st
2019 this also has to be some sort of
record in the sense of like waiting the
longest it is it is the record for the
song that waited the longest and it's
the first holiday song to reign a number
one since the chipmunks
in 1958 the one the chipmunk song in
1958 and Albin that's what I thought too
but it can't be no it can't be wait no
it's um the chipmunks the chipmunk song
yeah so obviously not the remake there
right see why would I know that there
was original um I think I think
Chipmunks alvin and his crew like they
are menaces by the way those movies are
excellent are they yes have you seen
them no the soundtrack is such a bob
they pick great songs to redo yeah also
Wow Blaine I it's just it's an excellent
movie and a great sequel also um but
what I was gonna say here is that this
is really a product of branding because
the song has always been popular during
Christmas time but in the last like two
or three years Mariah Carey's psych
social team has started to brand her as
like the queen of Christmas like she's
on tick tock now being like it's
November 1st not yet and then if she
wakes up on December 1st she's okay now
it's time this is very much like a
marketing thing and I feel as though
this might not have happened if she
hadn't had like a full social media and
like management team behind her like
trying to now brand her I was like the
queen of Christmas like she's been going
on tour only for Christmastime right
canceling those shows but still setting
up the tour but also um I was just
I saw someone on my Instagram two nights
ago go see her at Madison Square Garden
that was actually like really low-key
upset like I actually would have went to
that because she did a Christmas show
but she also sang like always be my baby
it was like a fusion of like her holiday
classics and also just like Mariah Carey
like pops oh I also got another
interesting factoid from my newsletter
this morning about Mariah and this
number one which is that she now has 19
songs that have hit number one and she's
just one win shy from the Beatles
all-time record it's so funny like which
is you crazy you have a newsletter for
all your like stats and I follow pop
crave on Twitter and it's like exactly
the same I didn't know that and when I
think of like the people with the most
number one I don't think more I know I'm
like Rihanna Beyonce Taylor Swift
yeah friends I don't know ya know Ghana
and like ABBA but you know what I mean
like I never just and but it actually
makes a lot of sense and that's why I
was thinking how I how I Sharon how I
wish I went to Santa Anna Lee think of
women Mariah Carey concert because I
would have known so many songs like she
like you don't think like I don't really
know but then she starts playing
something like oh I know this song yeah
you know no honestly knowing that she's
the second most number one singles is
the most shocking news I've heard all
day
yeah I never would have considered her
to be like a record holder but I do
consider her an icon but now I know she
that she is like a full blown record
holder it's incredibly impressive
incredibly impressive good for her I'm
happy for this song is like the best
Christmas song ever ever and it deserves
to be number one I want to thank all the
tick stalkers out there who contributed
to making this happen
by the way 1000% you by the way
they're crazy I need to get toast my
song like viral on Tik Tok because like
that makes or breaks songs and they're
like certain songs like go number one
without ever having left tick tock you
know Roxanne Roxon also la la la la la
la la la la la la la la la la la la I
use that in the Czech chocolate anime
been true comedy please feel free to
check it out at girls no job good stuff
congratulations Mariah Carey I'd love to
see it also at dinner with my friends
last night they were like ask me about
tick tock because they're like they like
our on Instagram but they're not like
social media they don't work in social
media so they were like what - tick tock
like I never asked me to show mine and I
was like [ __ ] embarrassed like look
even if it was like amazing content like
it's super fake internet friends here it
was like really and they were like
clicking stuff and I was like that's
humiliating
Margo can you not like it was know if I
can just block them no I know they don't
even have to talk so that's why they
were like playing around on mine and I
was like feeling so much shame I was
like you need to stop we have to make a
toast
tick tock challenge for the song toast
ok so we should really just have one
tick tock account like for all of us in
the toast but whatever very like you and
I yeah and like a toast brand yes we
should but first let's get ours up there
around them make a toast but no we just
have to make up a dance to the song
toast and then everyone will copy it and
that was viral okay I'll make it up yeah
because I'm gonna get up here
totally I heard she says hello she
always says hello I was just like so
warm like that
so is Mariah Carey Congrats Queen very
well guys I mean yeah I love to see it
okay Harvey Weinstein is in the news
because he sat down exclusively with New
York Post for an interview after dying
after back surgery was he doing press
well he mostly was doing press to like
show people that he wasn't exaggerating
about the Walker I guess of everything
that people are saying about him that
bothers me most using a fake Walker is
like the most egregious so the job using
the word of the year
thank you more than eighty women have
accused him of sex assault or harassment
we got 80 women but for Harvey Weinstein
it's still all about himself the alleged
serial sex predator and disgraced
Hollywood producer not Queen wined to
the post in an exclusive interview that
he should be remembered for doing more
professionally for women than anyone in
history rather than the slew of
sickening accusations against him the
fallen Tinseltown kingmaker appeared so
clueless that he even boasted about what
a lucrative contract he once gave
actress Gwyneth Paltrow what is alleged
victims quote I feel like The Forgotten
man he gripe I wish quote I made more
movies directed by women and about women
than any filmmaker and I'm talking about
30 years ago I'm not talking about now
when it's in vogue I did it first I
pioneered it he bragged it all got
eviscerated because of what happened he
said bitterly my work has been forgotten
but Weinstein talked to the post while
recuperating at New York Presbyterian
Weill Cornell Medical Center on Friday a
day after three-hour spinal surgery to
remove a trio of bone plates compressing
his vertebrae he sustained the back
injury in an August 17th car accident
this is so like not self-aware I don't
know who is surrounding Harvey Weinstein
whether it's like lawyers publicist
managers like they must be doing a
better job like this is the most out of
touch article and honestly like people
like this like monsters like I feel like
also shame on New York Post like you
shouldn't be giving people a platform
and making them famous you know what I
mean yeah is there any famous here ready
has a platform so it's like they're not
gonna turn down an opportunity to get an
exclusive interview with him like that's
what they do I know it's just like it
seems weird and it is like insight into
what's going on its its topic it's
interesting yeah it just seems like I
don't need to hear from him I'm so good
you know no I don't need to hear from
him okay cool that you actually broke
your back right allegedly well I know he
rented that room at the nearby Lake
Tyrian Hospital did he say anything
about why he wasn't using a walker and
enjoy it that's what we want to know are
they asking the hard-hitting question
right it's like you you're very
conveniently doing press in a hospital
being photographed outside the
courthouse with your Walker but it's
like when no one's around in Boston at
target the walkers nowhere to be found
and your back looks fine yeah so just go
back it's the thing
goodbye Harvey anyways interesting that
he like sees himself in that way I'm
getting to the point where I'm like
almost ready to China Harvey well I know
but it's like too important 9:00 yes I
really hate him because he's a monster
but it's like it has to be spoken about
right that's also how I feel about like
Jeffery up see like all the memes are
making me just like honestly like not
want to ever hear about him again but it
has to be spoken about yeah you know and
the only way that the victims get
justice is if we don't stop and we don't
forget right so here we are not
forgetting okay next story a little
uplifting news because Kanye West and
Joel Olsteen are taking their religious
road show on the road
Kanye West I didn't think road shows
take place on the road yeah Kanye West
and Joel Osteen know a good thing when
they see it and after a massive success
that you'll Sunday service in Houston
they've talked about a possible national
tour TMZ broke the story Kanye and Joel
will appear at Yankee Stadium on May 2nd
and they will almost certainly sell the
venue out ooh that is Zach's birthday
well oh but that's great but it's like
with Joel I feel like I know who has
know Jews we can go to Sunday service
regular but like Joel Osteen I don't
think we can I first I was like oh of
course I'll be there
yeah and it's like honey will be
responsible for the music Joel will
perform the service no like I'm good you
know maybe I can go like ask when the
music starts yeah it's kind of
respectful no it's like when we were
kids we used to see the Radio City
Rockettes and it's really like a good
like just like a Santa show like about
like cultural Christmas but then there's
like one scene where it's like Jesus
Nativity like I'm aunts Immaculate
Conception and like that was point we
were into the bathroom it's like we
don't need to see that yeah TMZ sources
say the next venue will be guaranteed
rate Field in Chicago Kanye's hometown
we're told that event will go down in
September okay if this is like this and
they're doing baseball fields but you
know it's crazy um if this is gonna
become like a big thing that's so
exciting that's I'm really cool it'll
take like a full-blown tour like I think
that's such a cool thing to do yeah um
Yankee Stadium has clear so I will
definitely think about going yeah I only
is cleared like that I now having been
the traveler who just like is obsessed
with clear like I'm literally turning
into the points girl do you see a
picture of TBG wearing his merch
with an icon yeah and he said litter he
took me that picture he's like I have
absolutely no idea how the shirt got in
my closet I didn't buy it that's cuz I
did you give it to me I'm like no dude
please no he like not only like he just
threw it in his bag because it was in
his closet but he hasn't no idea I'm
like maybe one of the girls in your
office like God ain't gave it to you he
like can't remember that shocking looks
so good on him no by the way totally by
the way disgrace clean shirts are
available in armored short there's not
that many left um it was like a you know
a spur-of-the-moment once-in-a-lifetime
race so if you want wine and you want to
meet this grey screen forever you better
get it and it won't be made again yeah
it was just like a moment in time where
we had to take on I need to tell a lot
nerve at all I have my disgraced
creature you have your disgraced future
it's so like we are set what's that yeah
for sure so we're the shirts for us yes
so get yours before you can't no Mel
stop morning tosaka curious to know like
how religious this will be like if they
are encouraging people other than
Christians to come or not right I think
with the Joel Osteen they might not be
but yeah unlike the OG Sunday service I
do think it's like a multi-faith yeah I
agree with that but then it's like yes
Joel Osteen is like obviously a
religious figure but he's also a species
so like maybe toasters can go me I do
think there's actually a discount code
if you Joel pseudocode toast yeah I
think so
it'll be interesting to see how they
incorporate those steamy vibes those
Osteen evac I've just accepted that
Kim's gonna be in New York honestly like
maybe more on interview that oh my god
he's always in New York that way we
never never because you know what she's
downtown Steen and you and I like never
go below like 34th Street yeah sure
sometimes she's uptown like for the met
but that's it no yeah like once a year
and she says at the mark yeah or the
Carlisle
anyways that'll be cool toasters like
get your tickets yeah and someone just
like give me a it's a kind of around me
of like lover fast you know like stadium
once a year we're gonna go to lover
dressed like I think little at Sadie I
know it's like not any orchids in Boston
like tickets are 1 7 1.7 million dollars
like what are we gonna do I don't know
but we could talk about how Taylor
second Joe all wins show rare oh my god
I thought you were gonna say Joel Osteen
so rare PDA term Oh Lou so I saw this
I'm like let me see him grab
harass they're holding me I thought they
were kissing on the red carpet yeah
they're holding hands under and then
walk the red carpet together they like
refused to acknowledge their
relationship they're like ScarJo and
Colin Jost which makes me think like
maybe this is you know the one for her
you know right and it also makes me
think soon we'll get like them on us and
I'll like smooching and we'll have
everything we ever need where the killer
is the musical guest and he's the host
he's not that famous yeah but like maybe
I would love that honestly like I'm like
the antithesis of cats the musical but I
do really want to see it they're doing a
great job marketing it obviously the
Taylor Swift did of it all but I'm down
to see how they CGI CGI'd jason Derulo's
penis out they said they had to take his
vault out he was on radio Andy's saying
Betty they had to take it out I'd love
to see aegis Alba and also I think we
need to talk about rubble Wilson for a
moment she's been very quiet but she
looks amazing
really have you seen her I didn't see
her on the centromere she looked
stunning
also breaking news this was like the
whole cat's premiere was like really
making headline news just like in
Hollywood gossip
Mimi Feldstein for the first time
stepped out with her girlfriend I saw
and Kelly Betts
oh of course that's why I was making
weight right I was rebel Wilson not at
the cat's premiere issue oh she's my
blue dress she's actually that's amazing
she's been like just so quietly like
churning out she's like been in a lot of
like movies recently like directing
she's really like just I feel like
falling into like this like great place
in her life yeah I love her so much
I meet you and I think the funniest
thing in the world is that her name is
rebel and her sister's name is Liberty
oh my gosh Liberty Wilson like their
parents are just like such like freedom
fighters like Patriots you know speaking
of rebels
I watched bring it on cheer smackdown
cheer shmacked
I supposed to know that is know it's
like the 12th in the bring it on
franchise and it was so glad this so
doing that and it was atrocious ha ha of
course I watched the whole thing and the
team is called the rebels and you know
what like by the end your garage Hills a
little bit like it was really I love a
cheerleading movie yeah I love a
cheerleading movie and it was like the
routines weren't my favorite they
weren't my favorite but it it was good
ok I just want to give an honorable
mention though to the one bring it on
spin off with Solange Knowles hayden
Panettiere and then that girl Whitney
who I took over as the chair captain at
the private school excellent film
excellent film and she's a falling in
love Winnie yes she was so evil Acker
was an amazing actress whatever happened
to like I really believe her about
- your smack that the like there is a
plot twist in the middle that like took
me that that's really I really didn't
see it coming wait then there's also
that other bring it on Jets versus
sharks oh yeah where they all fall in
the street I have to team up yeah yeah
good excellent excellent now that I
think about it it's actually like a
great franchise it's a great franchise
and like I just it's light-hearted fun
this one it was like a worldwide
conversation it was a worldwide
competition all virtual they really
incorporate social media like dedicate
vivica a Fox was the cheer goddess and
it's to works to her she was remote the
entire time like oh like Hunger Games
yeah because she was um she was like a
virtual coach sort of thing so it's like
she had to film in her bedroom in her
green room huh that's so funny yeah it
was really funny I mean you guys really
don't have to see it unless you've
enjoyed bad movies like me
III don't enjoy bad movies but I just
love seeing like a choreographed cheer
squad like putting on a performance
right and and and you get that okay I'd
love to see like you know what back
handspring back tuck right but you know
what no choreographed cheer squads are
ever better than the original bring it
on its roundoff back handspring back
tuck up roundoff back handspring
oh my god I'm gonna make it to time guys
that's a good idea
okay that's gonna gonna be I look fine
my nails I'll be like roundoff back
handspring
I just felt what she says alert yes um
well twisted layout Oh nobody sell my
idea i watch bring it on on the plane on
when we came home from Nashville
original yes like a month ago so good I
mean Gabrielle Union was just like so
stunning stands the test of time
incidence of time Kirsten Dunst like
dropping the spirit stick you're just
what I need you are just what I needed
so and then she's on her bed with the
pom-poms like you're just what I need
you're just what I need I'm feeling fine
I'm right on time I know I'll get my way
getting out in London mono mono channel
on to the ban that guy looks like that
guy is who plays her like fake boyfriend
is like a jewel a cliff fence actually
yeah well he was the original right but
like it's [ __ ] now that I think back in
time the fact that had gradually didn't
play that boy is like shock probably cuz
he was 12
okay so anyways taylor swifting show all
the by the way show the beautiful at the
cat's premiere they held hands under an
umbrella why is it always raining when
they step out together oh but that's a
good call it's like God is speaking stop
she looked to the God wants them to get
close under an umbrella so they could
hold him if I internet dressed on a
mannequin it would have been like no
ma'am but seeing it on tiller shipped I
was like yes ma'am so that's just shows
to tell you I know nothing about fashion
no sorry Celeste who's wearing Oscar de
la Renta and she was the snatchler I
love to see it love to see it classic
red lip thing that you like her job to
not walk the carpet together and I'm
just feeling like as a Stan like I'm and
I hate to as a fan of someone feel like
I'm entitled liking to know everything
and see everything about their
relationship and she's very open so if
this is the thing she decides to keep
private like you have no choice but to
understand but like I do get annoyed
like I just want to see them kiss or
something you have no choice but to
understand yeah but ya know even heard
that that courtesy for three years now
and you you deserve to be rewarded give
me something like I like the reward I
felt and even though I wasn't
intentionally waiting for Colin Jost and
Scarlett Johansson to like officially
acknowledge a relationship when they did
like it was everything I ever needed and
more right and they just in like a small
moment like that from Taylor Swift some
people are saying it's gonna happen at
the Met Gala this year that Geller and
Joe are gonna finally walk the carpet
together right because like her big
night at the AMAs I unclear if he was
even there she's like didn't nod to him
at SNL but she couldn't be nodding to
like Abigail we don't know who it was
like we just think it was him so um
there's like all these major moments
happening for a billboard woman in the
decade like huge things for her
personally professionally and she's like
where you at she had a huge 30th
birthday party like she'd even post a
picture like of a group with him you
know was he even there I don't know
right you could have thought they were
broken up but last night they were
together right we couldn't agree that we
could go for a little more but I feel
like with these like billboard women of
the decade sort of things it's all about
her in her career and stepping out with
Joe would take away from that that's
when the Mecca was perfect it's like
just
fashion and it's not about like anyone's
accomplishments right okay that's
actually a good call I'll wait till May
yeah first Monday and then we'll take up
arms okay until then I'm just gonna
hibernate fall asleep and then wake up
move it oh it's the first Monday May
where's Taylor's weapon Joe oh man I
just got the best thing of my life
thanks to memorize some people have
trouble falling asleep some people have
trouble staying asleep and some people
have trouble with both on average people
are getting less quality sleep than ever
before I definitely one of the people
who have trouble falling asleep like
once I'm asleep I'm good but like I'm up
all night like in my own head thinking
about emails I never responded to like
all the things thing and then I get
really deep it's like the longer I'm
awake I'm gonna be like well I'd be a
good mother I could get like really
really deep and it's like what does all
this mean you know exactly career
fleeting you you stay up too late and
all of a sudden you're going deep with
Andy Grammer totally tackling sleep
issues shouldn't feel impossible but
existing sleep aids aren't effective and
they make you groggy in the morning very
true and that's why there's REM rise a
personalized sleep solution that uses
natural plant-based formulas to help
calm the mind relax the body and get
your circadian rhythm back on track for
a better more restorative sleep so I
love Grammer eyes because right off the
bat you take a quiz you let them know
your issues we feel seeing you feel
heard my issue as well as had I had
trouble falling asleep once I'm asleep I
am good to go so I let them know that
and then they send you um packets daily
packets where night one ninety two
ninety three with different plant-based
um sleep aids that will help you fall it
like help you with your sleep issues and
I've been doing it for about two weeks
now and I really didn't like falling
asleep easier sleeping even better and I
just have so much more energy throughout
the day I don't wake up feeling like
groggy like no it's like if you took any
OPM yeah I'm a dive crazy dope yeah it's
drug for you with no groggy side effects
in the morning all you have to do is get
take a quiz at get REM rise calm slash
toast take their free sleep quiz we took
it it makes you feel see and makes you
feel heard we absolutely love a quiz
again that link is REM rise comm slash
toast then they'll come up with an
awesome digital app that you can use to
track your sleep progress and it even
has guided meditation to help you get in
the right mindset so do what we did
check out REM rise today go to get REM
rise calm slash to
to take their sleep quiz and when you
sign up and you get your first week of
REM rise free just pay for the shipping
you won't find an offer like this
anywhere else get your first week of REM
rise for free when you sign up at get
REM rise GE T REM R is a.com slash toast
get REM rise comm slash toast get REM
rods for free I'd get rid of my sock
comm slash toes get REM rise but free
we'd get ranma's comm slash toes someone
made a comment that is the most specific
person and best call I've ever heard in
my life I know you're talking about the
bring it on chats first sharks movies
Ashley lund Franco said the main shark
girl you remember her yeah is Gina from
Real Housewives of Orange County style
and SPO totally latinum blonde went that
they look alike but there's so much good
TV coming out to speak because we have
OC finale tonight and then we get the
first part is reunion this week we also
get Dallas reunion oh no doubt an ally
oh wow really good mm-hmm that's tonight
Wow good stuff you see Cameron watch
Scots Christmas tree no oh my god it's
like my dream tree really yeah I'm glad
I get to live vicariously through her
also I got a lot of gm's about our
conversation about Christmas trees
yesterday and a lot of people who are
Catholic or Christian giving me a lot of
insight into actually the spiritual
meaning behind a Christmas tree it's not
decorative it actually is like a it has
us forgot what it meant but it was like
it's a deeply were just saying it's
meant to represent like something in
Christ's life so it is weird but George
people have it yes it's just like a
personal decision it's not nothing like
there's you know we feel where it's like
we love celebrating Christmas as you
know yeah two things but like that makes
it to me it's like walking around with
wearing a necklace with a cross on it
like I would never do that
right okay fifth and final story is a
really exciting story straight off the
presses probably from Instagram is it
hot in here it's hot off the presses hot
off the presses from Instagram HQ
because they are taking more measures to
fight bullying online allegedly starting
today we are rolling out a new feature
that notifies people when their captions
on a photo or video may be considered
offensive and gives them a chance to
pause and reconsider their words before
posting oh where was this Teddy years
ago as part of our
turn commitment to lead the fight
against online bullying we developed and
tested AI that can recognize different
forms of bullying on Instagram earlier
this year we launched a feature that
notifies people when their comments may
be considered offensive before they're
posted results have been promising and
we found that these types of nudges can
encourage people to reconsider their
words when given a chance so if you
write like a caption
you're stupid something will pop up that
says this caption looks similar to
others that have been reported do you
want to edit your caption learn more or
share anyway oh my that's so funny that
they still give you the ability to share
right they're not like censoring you but
they're just like letting you know hey
you're an [ __ ] do you still want to
be an absolutely beautiful for your life
it's kind of how like when you're
sending a Gmail and you say hey I've
attached my resume and then there's no
attachment Google would be like hey
before you send this you say the word
attach yet there's no attachment would
you like to revise oh my god that has
saved me like 1 million just like saving
lives because if you're ever sending any
one attachment it's obviously something
important and like you will look like an
idiot it's not actually attached and
like I just think that is such a good
friend
yeah of Google when I was in NYU I sent
my internal media professor my
assignment and I actually ended up
sending a meme about ariana grande it
was like Starbucks Benteen Grande I was
like this dumb mean I can tell anyone
like hilarious memes where's your
assignment look sorry sir also that's
also a great way though to like be like
oh I thought I send it to you and then
you don't check your email you get
another Jen you get like those hours to
actually do this have a genius yeah
while this is an amazing thing that
Instagram is doing I feel as though it's
useless because I have an Instagram
account that doesn't receive any update
it's like I'm multiple Instagram
accounts on my Instagram app and like
clogged with no job like keeps getting
the new updates like girl with no job
still has a chronological comments she's
not able to sort by top comments like
it's never changed she still has likes
um whatever oh she doesn't have the
music feature like girl with no job if
you work in Instagram like please hit me
up girl with no job as stuck in the
Stone Age and every time Instagram rolls
out a new feature she doesn't get it Wow
the Clawd with no job does interesting
maybe they're like you can't have both
you have to choose club with no job that
has I'd also have the toast Instagram on
my phone
you can sort comments by topic we have
the music feature in stories so does
club but no job girl no job has nothing
interesting like Jackie O definitely is
slow to the rollout she doesn't she
still has likes but we have the muse
give me up top comment I don't have it
it's crazy like and I kind of like it
because sometimes I do look for a
comment by chronological and if I'm
doing it on going girls no job but if I
want to see like where my verified
comment came up on the Kim Kardashian's
Instagram yesterday or like I'll have to
go on cloud with no job just to find it
follow me by the way Club found me a
Jackie O problems it's not annoying that
is very well this is great it's not
gonna happen for me okay well you don't
have to infer the other people who come
and meet [ __ ] on your picture do we have
any toasty instagramers please help me
out like my Instagram is stuck in the
Stone Age really annoying really
annoying so bottom anything that this is
like a little Big Brother style but you
know what it's like the whole world is
Big Brother style they're using your
information they know everything about
you it's like maybe we could just get
some nice comments right and this sex
she's like a really hot topic right now
talking about whether phone companies
should like work with the government
like if someone's committed of a crime
but they won't for over your
personalized information um and I'm like
of the mindset where it's like I don't
really have anything to hide like I'm
not like committing crimes in my DM so
I'm kind of okay with like Verizon
handing over like if it's gonna help
someone like solve a crime yeah I
understand and I feel that way too but
it's just like it sets a bad precedent
no I totally get it but it's like I keep
watching SVU and there's certain
episodes were like they're fighting with
phone companies to like get a phone
unlocked because they answer to the cry
like where is this girlfriend kidnapped
he's on the phone and like the phone
companies like won't corroborate and
it's just like frustrating and I get
that it's like a hot-button issue and I
obviously of course see both sides but
to me it's like I truly like my phone
I'm an open book like I'll just be
embarrassed by like the loser things
that I do but I won't be committing any
crime so like honestly fork it over no
and I just feel as though yeah in
general like we shouldn't be invading
people's privacy but our privacy has
already been invaded and like you're
using our information in the way that
you see fit so like you might as well
like help me if I get kidnapped totally
when my Amber Alert goes out yeah I know
yeah so I'm sure people have you know
varying opinions on the subject that's
just how sue sees it love it there's so
many references today
did you see Leah Michelle and Jonathan
grow up on Jimmy Fallon
no but it was how you were watching when
I came in here yeah Jimmy Fallon was
actually being really funny and I'm not
gonna lie Jonathan Groff was like a
little pitchy and I just wish he let
Leah Michelle saying more like she's the
truth star like just let her saying but
I didn't realize until we podcasted with
Leah Michelle that Jonathan Groff is
Sven in frozen
so we yeah yes
skyy yes so now when I hear I'm saying
I'm like spent like he is so spend
that's like the hard thing about putting
celebrities and that was like what we
were talking about the Lion King putting
celebrities in animated voice like rolls
it like ruins them for me
especially when the when the movie takes
on the life of its own that's like I
can't hear Mindy Kaling speak without
thinking of inside out like the best
movie ever I haven't seen it what I know
there's a lot of animated movies that
I've been meaning to see okay okay
that's what I have to mentally remember
cuz I feel like I'm Michelle Maui saying
I mean it scene it means D and then I go
home at a time and I don't know what to
say okay inside out you bring it on
chair smack Jackie Brittain inside-out
is a movie that look I wish we have as
kids it like teaches kids things like
I'm learning now as an adult like how
your memories are so important like sir
it's beautifully done like the movie is
like stunning bright so plan E but like
the whole it's about like characters who
live inside your brain all your emotions
like Mindy Kaling it's happiness joy and
it's so cute and so it's such a good
movie okay it's a cry I also really want
to watch Coco that's awesome that's like
number one I also Sven is the reindeer
and Kristoff is Jonathan oh man yes but
they're the same reindeers are better
than people one more thing about
yesterday's episode when we were talking
about Kansas City it is worth noting
that someone DM to me out some facts
Kansas City borders on Kansas and
Missouri okay but it's so it's like it's
like a thing it's like a pride thing
like people who live in the Missouri
part or like Kansas City's in Missouri
then people who live in the Kansas part
like Kansas is in Kansas City it should
be called oh that's interesting fight
you guys got going on maybe called
Kansas City Limits because it's like the
on the border and I kind of fell in love
with Austin City Limits
I love Kacey Musgraves sheets early
stream music there's a story that we do
in our patreon this week where we talk
about how we wanted to write things down
more so we can remember things that we
wanted to talk about on the show and
there's one thing that I've been trying
to remember each day this week to talk
about because I really want to get your
opinion on it
TLC announced a new show called hot and
heavy have you seen this I saw a bunch
of women in a hot tub oh and actually
it's on the trailer about their men
talking about how they wish they would
gain more weight it's a show about quote
mixed weight relationships okay another
thing right and but so it's people in
relationships who are different weights
and like any other relationship but all
of the women are the overweight ones
where the men are the average Joe Joe's
and it's like really [ __ ] up and I
just saw your thoughts weird and
obviously and they don't even address it
they just act like it's normal
relationships but it's obviously men who
have fetishes of overweight women and
they keep talking about they wish it
would gain more weight like and making
them so unhealthy like first of all like
just to to treat like any weight as like
a fetish is so [ __ ] weird and
disgusting
like it's just when your TLC takes it
too far sometimes yeah sister wives like
I this is just not for me yeah not for
me it's like so no no it's weird but
like that's what that like their trailer
went viral and like that's what they
live for
yeah so I guess they'll consider this a
success but it's highly offensive and
just weird like I can't they need to
bring back my strange addiction that's
what they need you no longer on remember
the woman who used to eat her husband's
ashes or something what was she gonna do
when she ran out that's how she needed
to stop right also the woman who eats
furniture the man who's in love with his
inflatable dolphin like that was such an
amazing show it was the ones when people
would eat like Oh the girl who would
like lick nail polish oh my god
disgusting such a good show the one
who's in love with his lamp like they
really need to bring that back they
actually have like an amazing slate of
TLC content on YouTube I mean not
YouTube sorry Netflix they have a
million episodes of Extreme Couponing
which is literally the best show like
the fact that people would go grocery
shopping spend a thousand dollars and
this grocery store would end up owing
them money amazing extreme cheapskates
like people who would shower together
and they only allowed to shower once a
week for like 60 seconds because they
would try and preserve the water you
can't flush you pee outside they would
pick up roadkill and eat it like extreme
cheapskates go into a bakery oh and then
like certain episodes had themes like
this couple was trying to throw a
birthday party on like a 25 dollar
budget and they would like go to
different bakeries and try to negotiate
for like expired cakes such a good show
check it out there have it on Netflix
Wow I didn't know any of that check it
out if I can ever remember
that's a slate of content that they
should be like churning out not shows
like fetishizing women I I totally agree
anyways I think that's all we got for
you make sure you head over to shop
morning toast calm as our merch is a
limited stock
left make sure you order it now to get
it for the holidays people are getting
their merch now and the content is so
pretty
everything everything make sure you can
get your holiday stuff winter stuff
vintage stuff there's a lot of
accessories there's a lot of stuff on
sale from previous drops so there's
really something for everyone such great
stocking stuffers if you need a last
minute gift friend extra stockings and
actual stockings if you need a
last-minute gift for the toaster in your
life like they're just gonna be like oh
my god how did you procure that yeah how
did you know you know you know um thank
you so much for listening to the morning
shows the Millennial morning show where
we go live excuse me I just burps Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please subscribe give this video
a thumbs up leave a little comment we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio iHeartRadio
cashbox you know if you're listening as
a podcast wherever you choose to listen
feel free to subscribe leave a five star
review about how standing smart and
beautiful we are I love you guys so much
move back to be back tomorrow Wednesday
for a little hump day action will be
doing deer toast toast tomorrow and
recapping the real how was Orange County
finale and the real hospitality but now
let me hope you have an amazing day love
you so much follow me on tic toc girl
with no job pal man Instagram tick tock
at jackieo problems we love you so much
you